what do you think about the uh these  kids who got really famous from uh what  happened in Parkland they started  becoming uh I think for the most part  the media props up this bunch of this  group of young people who are very much  gun control activists yeah but then you  had uh Kyle uh Kashif I'm probably  pronouncing your name wrong Kyle who is  more Pro 2A I'm curious your thoughts on  you know how the media handled it well  like I said they focused on just the gun  control and they didn't accomplish  anything but registered Democrats that's  all those kids accomplished when it came  time for running School Board Races they  were nowhere to be seen when it came  time to get rid of the sheriff nowhere  to be seen getting bills passed Common  Sense bills for school safety there were  nowhere to be seen but me and other  couple of parents and my family my sons  we were at it like non-stop to hold  people accountable